[Music]
every single mechanics been built to be
social exactly always we start with the
world Matt I'm a co-op perspective we
want the person on the wheel to be able
to sail the ship and see where they're
going on the map and do everything all
in one splitting it up so that the world
maps on the middle deck as a deliberate
decision so that the line of sight is
broken so crew mate needs to go down
there have a look shout up to the guy on
the wheel like all we need to go north
and the likewise not all the
informations on the map either the
person on the wheel has some information
the person on the map has other
information like all all the kind of
rocks and like smaller nuances of the
world design you have to see them like
from from the whale to see the all of
the rocks and reefs that a player in the
crow's nest saw hanging out in front of
the ships gonna be able to see that
information so you all need to work
together to give each other the
information that you need to navigate I
think for me the breakthrough was the
map like when I think back to when my
first prototype inquests it was getting
the map in which was just a singular map
at the time that only one person could
carry and that kind of enforced through
social mechanics around looking at it
and showing it to your crew and remember
the first place that's what we had when
like you were showing the map it was
awesome it was like and you were
physically showing it to them and you
were seeing them a hood all around you
and first person you're on to something
here that we need to build off this that
was the start of it cause like the
cooperative digging came a lot later
actually didn't I yeah before it was
just like a singular person digging yeah
so see a singular person have the shovel
a singular person had the man and
basically it meant that people were more
like kind of forced into roles which we
didn't we didn't want and we wanted
everyone to have the ability to do any
role at any time and actually just made
it blossom ins being even even more
socially the best type of social that we
wants it because soon as we gave up on
the shovel it felt like well let's let
everybody dig it up together and it be
faster so when you've got to the to the
treasure and dug it up it doesn't end
there because the minute you dig up that
chest it's only a risk for a certain
amount of time basically that that's the
crucial thing to remember your hands if
you if you get it back safely literally
if you get it back safely to an outpost
and sell it to the ship right
it's true it's fine it's it's your it's
your goal but once you've dug it up
that's it
if there's somebody nearby if they if
they shoot you if they kill you or they
overcome you they can steal that
probably technically not your goal then
anyway that's what makes it so tense and
so enjoyable for me you kind of like
naturally just designate roles but I'll
quote someone protect me because it's
just instinctive to get someone to like
follow you with a blunderbuss or with a
fist or someone like Scout ahead a
little bit or there's a very deliberate
design decision to make that the chest
read some think that is a shared benefit
for the whole crew so it's something
that you all rally around it bonds you
together and it's something that you all
want to protect I gather it's great on
the other side though as well like
there's nothing better than cashing in a
chance it was someone else's hard work
yeah I think that it going on the cross
is kind of a culmination of all these
cooperative mechanics where this pirate
crew is bonded together going on our
adventure together
yeah with these set of tools they can
all work together you can all cooperate
collaborate together this goal will have
treasure in mind yeah exactly
[Music]
you